[Applause]
[Music]
did not lay low as he took the stage at
the 2022 grammys to perform industry
baby with jack harlow my track record is
so clean they couldn't wait to just bash
me i must be getting too flashy y'all
shouldn't let the world guess me before
the duo lit up the stage together lol
naz kicked off the performance singing a
different song dead right now while also
serving some looks starting with a black
sparkling cape soon disrobing into a one
shoulder number during a snippet of
montero
[Music]
and of course switching up his look one
more time for his controversial mega hit
with jack ahead of the show doji cat
revealed to et that it wasn't easy
getting her pal to spill details on his
highly anticipated performance i don't
know and he still texts me stuff but he
doesn't text me enough like i don't know
what he's about to do tonight but i just
know it's gonna be great she wasn't
wrong talk about an unforgettable
performance check out this cute moment
of the two friends after the rapper hit
the stage having a blast and grabbing a
snack inside the ceremony the 22 year
old was up for five trophies on grammy
night including top awards like album of
the year record of the year song of the
year after taking a nearly four month
social media hiatus little nazaks made a
surprise return to announce he's almost
finished with a new album something he
also told et on the red carpet all right
last thing what does it mean you just
came off maternity leave
what is that it's go ahead i'ma let you
there's another bunny in the oven so
there's another one in the oven it's
coming i've been i'm announcing right
now guys yes the singer is not the only
one working on new music his
collaborator also teased some fresh hits
coming very soon all the nominations
tonight how excited are you about that
incredibly and hungry focused i'm about
to drop i'm about to drop a song this
week that's going to be nominated next
year oh so this is enough you're like i
need i got this
i want this but i'm
tunnel vision focused on the future
hungry
[Music]
you